you know what this is such a deep part
of my childhood I can't go to the who's
hotter in the in the Brady Bunch yeah
that's too hard maybe Cindy Cindy may
have hit rough times you know young
Charles and Brady Bunch's now yeah yeah
okay go Alice I remember when the
annales guy
Andy gave us goddamn right you're a
Nambu Davis guy all call me say I'm the
butcher
[Music]
it's the bonfire Comedy Central radio
sirius XM 95 it's very important Jacob
was getting us all wired up where is the
man he would love that you did that how
much we were saying Comedy Central radio
sirius XM 95 oh you identified yes just
to make sure we weren't like a communist
radio I think we stopped saying coming
to the radio series 1695 big Jay
oakerson Dan Soder every time we come
back I think it's the first one yes yeah
set it up but we said it we say every
time moronic
our guest joining us in the studio right
now Pete Holmes and Judd Apatow Judd it
took a second took em a second yeah sure
sure I would know I mean you could be an
ax vape commercial the weed ones the
ones roasted the guys I look everybody
in those videos of guys like making all
realize that my kids have shown me like
people do amazing smoke things but those
things like the jewel are the most
addictive thing on the earth and all
middle schoolers are like crackheads
with jewels that's my question for you
as a parent because I started smoking
Jathan I start smoking like 12 but I'm
smoking cigarettes so Jules now for
middle school kids it's less like you
started smoking my daughter told me last
night
- first of all my favorite thing was
jump all in fire was sloppy
we have no structure my daughter said
last night cuz Christine was looking for
her jewel and my daughter goes
jool is that like the long rectangle one
you know like she absolutely knows which
one is but then they say her school like
I don't know is this is dangerous or not
are they magnetizing the bathroom
because it makes the jewels won't work
or something yeah the poor guys just me
where's my jewel not working where if
you touch this one brick my jewels
operating under the fourth prime
directive do not work in school do that
so that's a hilarious thing to
equip the bathrooms with anti jewel
that's what I always appreciate it said
wah wah made all the lights all the
lighting in their bathrooms blue so you
can't find a vein to shoot up heroin in
the bathroom really and they make a
quality spot 24/7 how big of a junkie
was the guy that pitched that he goes
guys I mean we could do blue lights
can't find a vein George I'm trying to
stay clean if you like there's a whole
world I don't know much about gas they
should say what is our specialty
oh wow a bathroom waiting Wawa is a East
Coast asking for water no it's the East
Coast sandwich shop East Coast sandwich
but it's a sandwich gas station sandwich
shop oh so it's a gas station go for the
sandwiches and if you need to refill
that's how they lure you in then you get
into the store look at this store you
call him at a gas station you're saying
that you've never been more Philly than
you like a long you know you're trucker
and you you're driving long distances
you want food that clogs you up yeah you
don't want food that keeps it yeah
you're a trucker and your route has
blessed you by passing a Wawa and you
don't stop in there I mean unless you're
looking to shoot heroin
you're just with someone and you go I
can't go to Wawa I got blue lights are
you going
he's like that's fine no I smoke meth so
it doesn't matter I don't need light she
goes actually like the list they take me
down for my violent stage what else
would the blue lights stop you from
doing that's it make a poster we're sick
also wear a t-shirt with a mustard what
would it do show all of your fake teeth
show all of your dental flaws it doesn't
look like a story you'd have to be rode
hypnotized by a 90-mile Hall I think
it's a store or BJ I wish we could yeah
you could just BJ in the tailgate
I wish we had Wawa sandwiches for you
guys both to eat in front of us I'm good
on diary
it's the cork I don't know four o'clock
yeah I think it almost makes your
regular it's fantastic food but what if
you're a judge trucker and you're like
okay I got a job I've got 2,000 miles
ahead of me and then you get in your car
and you have your coffee and then 30
seconds later you're like I gotta take
every 20 minutes for 2100 in second gear
that's the code for filling up them
trousers know you spoke speak AM radio
just what you got a guy on the line with
record breaker 1 to Jay has anyone ever
thought when you said my name is big Jay
oakerson that you were spelling it out
and that it was Jo Carson with a capital
J yes what's your name big Jay oakerson
oh yeah start with the J then go
oakerson I'll get you all there
I never noticed it myself until somebody
would just make my name on like who
wanted to start in the black circuit
sometimes they would just write big and
in the letter J that's not how I ever
thought like big J yeah this is like the
letter J so big Jay oakerson looks like
big Joker so yes isn't wasn't Bill burr
in the when he did the black circuit
Billy burr wasn't that his thing I think
he was Billy bear across the board and
then
the board Billy burns and one shot at
the seller says Billy Burke it does yeah
I think one day he just said how old do
you have to get and still be called
Billy hilarious that was told me I can't
go Billy anymore I only ever knew bill
is like the greatest and like a legend
and I opened for him when I was first
starting out and he was headlining it
was at Peoria it was a place called Ice
House or something in Peoria doesn't
matter so I get back to and I get to New
York I see gaff again this is 10-15
years ago and I go yeah I was just in
blah blah opening for Bill burr and he
goes bill Heber it was so long ago he
couldn't believe that Bill burr was
headline you can you just let that soak
in there was a time that we knew bill
burr he can't be strong gentle you can't
believe do two Friedlander's headline
now either do that's hilarious just to
think there was a time that someone was
like Richie Pryor Griffin called them on
the first appearance oh really is Richie
Pryor yeah that's the label come little
Richie price George Carlin is looking to
do it's due in an hour it's never gonna
be able to fill an hour
Billy Cosby a real Ladykiller in the
back Cosby oh man sharper in the
back of a toothbrush get extra
cornbread is he bragging about being
Bill Cosby we're trying to tell people
he's not Bill Cosby I think they have
him in a wing where he doesn't see any
other gen-pop yeah he's not in there
he's not in there with the animals he's
he's got that milky I just sit in a
corner till an old war story smoking a
cigar prison yo man I'm murder
to gosh speak English speak English
bollocks will not work in this certain
play area simply speaks English
isn't for the veins of your veins you
can't find them well I'm available go
call my aides on the bus we were trying
to think of the worst stand-up material
that you could do for David ah for his
character Jason and what we landed on
I'm crashing HP premieres January at
10:00 p.m.
company central radio sirius is big je
and what we decided was the worst bit
that we we made a stand a bit out of was
Bill Cosby's graduation speech from a
long time ago where his big running joke
was that he was mocking the concept of
consent so you gotta ask people gonna
work and he literally did a whole
routine at a graduation Jesus wait
that's a real thing no yeah and it's in
a book like he he put his laws be marked
consent yeah I had a graduate
talk about it's like what serial killers
do to wave a thumb and the nose
of the detective yeah that's credit the
level of clues you ignore them free just
when they busted it in his house in
Philadelphia he turned in a chair goes
gentlemen I would expect the use since
the late seventies
so long I've gone through several plates
draw I started to believe on it do it
[Music]
exactly there's a whole article they
were there pulling up with em they found
this weird yeah in the voyage yeah in
the book Cosby tells readers how lucky
they are to have graduated since they no
longer have to deal with campus sex
police and a chapter titled no more pre
caressing agreements Cosby describes how
silly it is that men need to get
permission and have sexual relations
with women they find attractive I mean
say what you will about Bill Cosby I
stayed on brand for decades
the guy operated on cro-magnon law yeah
came up over the Dolman triangle Bob
Murphy with the dupe in the Bing I mean
it's crazy they got to keep him
by himself in prison yeah cuz everyone I
bet there's a lot of people's stories
and brag to the guys he did a drive-by
drivin him just describing he becomes
you know I always find like some old
wise guy in prison to help them with
their like like to get ya um a
Muslim yeah to make but to make bail we
were talking about that with three
Martinez like I wonder if Cosby becomes
there because he's a doctor
like a doctor can you help me out I'm
trying to argue in front of the parole
board because he's a stand-up you know
he misses doing Seanna he must want a
gaggle of people around him all daily
yeah I don't think he's sitting alone in
the thing there he's trying to volunteer
somehow yeah I'd probably try to pony up
I'll do the laundry
you idiot protect the cause and if I was
like no no I tried to be friends with
them because you know they're probably
some good security is gen-pop listen
Pete Wow on some of us weren't some
gangs were not too proud of but you do
it to survive
you think the ultimate punishment is the
off-brand pudding in prison now can they
please be given to me sealed I don't
trust you from your personal chef for 50
years yeah that's gotta be part of what
is unpleasant beds like the you know the
beds he's been wealthy for over four
decades so his beds are like this thick
in padding and now he's just on that
slime that like thin slab if you think
wahwah is a store you won't mind prison
yeah chef like an omelet chef every
morning if you think Y was a store
you're just correct you just have
traveled this great land
if prison food is like Wawa food well
then sign this guy up I'm gonna shoot
this guy in the head right what do you
do off DJ Lou yeah I'll do it
tell me I go wah wah every day and I get
to talk to the cause I get to write my
slam poet I swam poems but you know
somebody there's like a lab for all the
the WHA food and there's a couple where
that's you know what are the heads of
the company is like trying the new
hamburger yeah this is fantastic like
you know there's a massive process for
every product yeah oh absolutely I did I
do like a little test true drops like
yeah now that tastes like ranch
you